yeah i'm so excited this political
thriller dead lies it's written by
hilary bonner who's an unbelievable
best-selling crime author and reading
this story is just
filled with twists and turns and scandal
and it was just so gripping i
am i feel so privileged and thankful to
get to be a part of such an amazing cast
with some real
british heavy hitters in the acting
world like clive mantle
and yeah it's an unbelievable story so
we'll be on tour soon and you can get
tickets on deadlife.co.uk
there we go tell me where your
inspiration is coming from
for the role what's your what's your
role
well i play kate compton who's the press
secretary for what might potentially be
the next prime minister
and i have been doing so much research
and just sort of getting
to grips with alan cummings and uh with
aleister campbell and
just doing a lot of research to really
get to understand
just who kate compton is where she comes
from and where she's going because uh
yeah i feel a huge amount of
responsibility to bring
a lot to the table when it comes to this
play and how long are you are you on
tour what's that what's the plan
yeah so we start to uh what uh september
and we'll be there
touring the uk until november um so yeah
please come and
come and see us do you prefer acting or
singing
i mean i'm loving acting at the minute
you know i just finished three series of
almost never i've done some independent
features
and some short films and things and you
know i've danced and performed my whole
life and this just feels like
the next adventure the next chapter for
me as a performer and yeah it's like
you know dance was my first love and as
i'm now a mom of three
and um and sort of going into that next
chapter
acting and performing and being able to
do what i love and transfer it into
acting has just been an absolute dream
so yeah i love it
what's the little one called this is
maple
hello maple how are you how proud are
you of your mummy
you want to wave to us quick wave
no no i'm not just going to perform just
because you want me to
speaking of that we kimberly we were
looking at potentially going on a world
tour with the pussycat dolls but then of
course
that was postponed wasn't it yeah it's
been quite the whirlwind
we did all the promo we were ready to go
on tour and then of course we've been
thrust into lockdowns and
so tour is still potentially happening
but it's looking more like
uh late next year in september so i've
just been really grateful that there's
been other amazing things to sink my
teeth into like dead lies
okay well good luck with that um
thankfully she found her her dummy so
she'll be much happier now
bye the juggle okay i'm working
ah lovely to see you thanks a lot take
care well good luck with the play thank
you